so why don't we just turn it right over
to Stefan and you can do your
present hi everyone I'm Stephan espito
from Harvard X and how do I Advance this
all right so I'm going to give you a
sort of a brief overview of how we've
been doing the humanities at Harvard X
um at Harvard X we're really interested
in finding Innovative and fun ways to
teach the humanities online and so I'm
just going to give you a SM mattering of
uh pictures and techniques that we've
used so this is the ancient Greek hero
uh with Greg n and here we recruited a
team of people who had taken the course
before in the brick and morar
environment to serve as teaching fellows
online and it created a really Dynamic
atmosphere people loved it the previous
alumni loved it as well here we have
Justice with Michael sandel who's kind
of a star he's very big in Japan
supposedly um but we had interactive
polling of like who would you kill with
a trolley under certain scenarios and
then link that to the discussion forum
so people could simulate the sort of
inperson classroom environment where
you're really telling each other what is
right and what is wrong um this is Lisa
news poetry in America course which is
humongous course and the most
interesting thing she's doing here is uh
interfacing with celebrities so Bill
Clinton is going to read a poem for her
and talk about the importance of poetry
in America and for American history um
we're also using a Harvard X developed
annotation tool in this course uh which
there's a concurrent presentation right
now by Leen Phil about that tool so if
you're way more interested in that then
in this course you should run out now um
but and then there's China X which we
had a a glimpse of in the previous
session and they're doing a lot of stuff
with 3D imaging um breaking things into
smaller modules and using GIS
mapping um this is early Christianity
which oddly enough partnered with Rap
Genius to do annotations for the Bible
so now you can get Tupac and St Paul in
the same place um now we have tangible
things which is pioneering the use of
documentary style as much as possible um
here we have Shakespeare's World which
is also going to be modular the
professor here is very busy as many
professors are doesn't want to do a full
course so he's going to do snippets on
Hamlet on Romeo and Juliet and the most
interesting takeaway from those plays um
here we have visualizing Japan which is
a collaboration between Harvard and MIT
to draw upon some of the collections
they both enjoy um the history of the
book is going to be a
modular course series of courses from
Harvard x uh and we're bringing together
10 faculty to teach a bunch of different
topics um and they will be using some of
the neat tools we've developed including
this time map for uh letters of Paul
Mirador which is a document annotation
and imaging thing which draws on
Harvard's resources and The annotation
tool which I mentioned before um so
Humanities and mukes there's a lot going
on there should be a lot more I'm done
thank you very much we can talk
later oh you're going to help G
help
thank you so
much hi I'm David maer I'm with the
center for 21st century Universities at
Georgia Institute of Technology I'm a
senior research scientist there and I'm
going to share with you a collaboration
between the school of electrical and
Computing and the center where I work uh
the National Academy for Education
transformation states that there are are
five things that you have to consider
when you redesign a course one is to
make the course active one is to give
students sufficient time on task and to
monitor that progress another is to give
the students individual
assessment one is assessment with
immediate feedback and if you're going
to overhaul the course you must consider
course drift course drift that is the
phenomenon where you have multiple
sections of a course taught by multiple
instructor
taught multiple ways and at Georgia Tech
what we did was we wanted to try to
minimize course drift in a course
entitled uh circuits and electronics ECE
3710 it started out as a traditional
lecture course and now I'm going to
share with you how it was revised
redesigned and I'll share some results
with you as well so course drift I told
you about that there were nine sections
of a course taught by nine different
instructors taught nine different ways
course drift we wanted to deliver the
content to the students across all
courses the same way we decided to use a
moo the moo delivered the content and we
used a blended learning environment
where class time about 10 minutes
students were given a summary of what
they saw the night before and then they
moved into problem solving and
experiment
mentation one interesting thing about
the uh course was that Hands-On
activities were taken into the course
brought into lecture hall similar to
this some classrooms also students got
to
manipulate um the equipment making
abstract Concepts
concrete uh if a picture is worth a
thousand words a Hands-On activity is
worth a th000 pictures how can you get
the students to picture and talk about
the same things just in time teaching
another thing students come to class
with algorithmic problem solving skills
how do you move away from that getting
the students to think about design and
solving problems just in time tutoring
that helped I want to sh oh and also
with the instructors the instructors had
professional development and it was
sustained throughout the semester
imagine having a course of perhaps 900
um I mean throughout the year 900 to a
th000 students enrolled in it and each
semester you could have a different set
of teachers or instructors for the
course sustained professional
development will help with that you can
talk about best practices Etc on the uh
on your right there is a graph there was
a concept inventory that was
administered you can see from pre to
post test that there were significant
gains in six of the nine sections that
were taught you can ask me more
questions later about this my time is up
thank
you hi my name is Bernard cooperman I
teach at the University of Maryland um
I'm this is just approve that I have
taught a course AO it was very
successful it was a corsera course we
had about N9 or 10,000 people who signed
up you know at the beginning of course
only about 10 or 15% of that finished
the course but we got very good feedback
from the people I want to say that at
the beginning because I really uh want
to question the validity of muks I want
to stress to you that muks are a
technology they are a Technology based
product and like all Technologies they
will pass like realtoreal tape recorders
and the structured learning programs in
language that I was taught language with
those are all now in garbage dumps
everywhere and you can't find those
courses anymore they don't exist uh you
can see the tape recorder there uh I
don't know if any of you remember tape
recorders but I do um not only is uh it
a technology that will pass it is an
expensive technology it therefore must
seek and create like all Technologies
its own justification ations its
viability requires a profitability model
which we call scaling so that it's worth
spending all this money it creates
moreover its own presentation
possibilities you can do things on mukes
you can't do uh in the classroom but
also
limitations um marketing and research
the much of what's gone on here at this
conference and and certainly what we all
read
emphasizes uh student learning learning
techniques how to get students to learn
how to make things go we very little is
talked about with muks with the actual
content of the information itself how it
relates to the discipline and so forth
we stress the short attention span of
the students cor Sarah tells its
instructors to keep the lectures down to
eight minutes by preference um there is
a desire for constant feedback to the
students which we call interactivity but
it's basically a way of stimulating them
to keep them from falling asleep because
we assume that they can't pay attention
for longer than just a few minutes I
hope I'm being aggravating enough and
silly enough now the question is does
this work for the Humanities the trouble
with the humanities in part is that the
method and the substance of humanities
teaching and history teaching and poetry
and so forth is highly unstructured and
experiential you don't know a poem in
the way you may know a a fact of
geography or know how to solve a problem
you experience it and you experience it
uniquely each person experiences that
poem differently and therefore the kinds
of questions you can ask and the gring
you could do at the end is much more
limited this all this problem is part of
what is called the crisis of the
humanities humanists who are all
paranoid I assure you I am part of that
group we blame the younger generation
who can't think we blame the scientists
who really run the university all of
that is paranoia the truth is that the
consumption of knowledge in our society
has changed fundamentally memory has
lost its function and many of the
aspects of Humanity's teaching I'm out
of time I've just got one more slide
many of the Humanity's aspects of
teaching uh have lost their social uh uh
social value including handwriting what
can we do I think that Ms can continue
and I think they're fine and I enjoy
teaching mine and I'm teaching it again
and I will do more of them but I think
what m should do for the Humanities is
to do what universities can't in
addition to advertising what MIT or
Harvard whatever have to to show uh on
screen I think what we should be doing
is inventing mukes that can do what we
cannot do in the universities we can't
teach language in the universities we
should use muks to teach language in the
same way that KH Academy does we should
build up a library of publicly
accessible resources for students to use
outside of the moo class that has not
been done as part of the moo despite the
rhetoric we've heard here and that's
important thank
you
hi everyone I'm Alison Duan and this is
Kristen echelman we direct Davidson X at
Davidson College which is a small Liber
arts school in North Carolina so a key
reason that colleges and universities
are experimenting with mukes today is to
explore how these emerging Technologies
are impacting the core of teaching and
learning on campus both in terms of
quality accessibility and afford ility
this is a the the motivation behind a
qualitative study that we're excited to
be running on two courses at Davidson
College's fall which specifically looks
at how these mukes that are being run in
conjunction with residential courses are
impacting the quality of the student
learner experience and of the faculty
teaching experience so the first uh
course that will be a case study is a
stem course that will be taught for the
second time it will be first taught uh
to flip the residential course and then
those residential Learners will then
serve as Tas during the second half of
the course as they continue also with
their uh regular cour work they'll then
be authors of course content which will
become case studies in the last week of
that course the second case study will
be on a Humanities course and the the
the basic uh structure of the
residential experience won't change
significantly however those students
will be Tas in the moo version of this
course that will run in conjunction and
they'll also become curators of cultural
artifacts that will be displayed on a uh
collections platform called
omea okay so we want to understand
really what works in this scenario and
lacking the resources at a small College
we decided to do a design Jam we were
inspired by one we attended with George
Seamans uh back in in the fall uh so
you'll see the members up on the board
here and I left out one person very
important person Daniel saton from mit2
is also participating um that design Jam
started this summer it is continuing
into this week where we're doing the
tweaking of the final questions for the
pre- and post surveys and for the
interview protocol questions um the
study will kick off in two weeks uh
it'll last the course of the semester um
it will include typical Dan typical
qualitative uh methods um observation
focus groups interviews surveys uh and
then we hope to combine it with some of
the quantitative data that's coming out
of the edex platform we're using a data
scientist who's a Davidson Alum to help
us uh generate some weekly and then end
of course summary reports so that we can
pull together a quantitative and
qualitative study um what we're hoping
this study will do is address what we
think are three lacking elements of Muk
research at the moment uh qualitative
research in general and we're really
inspired by Amy and George in that
regard um the work that they're doing is
amazing and I recommend checking it out
uh quickly uh in addition we want to
give our students a voice to me that's
the most important piece of all of this
uh and we want to see if muks can
transform a residential education so
we'll have the results in February uh we
invite you to take a look at those and
if you want to contact us our
information is on the slide thank
you
good afternoon everyone so as we tackle
some of the big questions about mukes
here at the workshop often with really
big data sets I want to just take three
minutes and um bring us back to what we
might call nearfield effects so these
are some of the oncampus close range um
implications for teaching mukes so at
Caltech the desire to stimulate um
innovation in on campus teaching and
learning actually motivates campus
faculty and leaders to be in this world
um even more than enhancing the brand or
generating revenue or providing
broad-based educational resources
although those are absolutely in the mix
too so it's very reasonable to ask what
are Muk stimulating on campus and that
is a particularly relevant question as
in the stem field we do have this
persistent lag between adopting
evidence-based practices um and and
knowing what they are um so so far we
have three broad categories of nearfield
innovation related to mukes flipped
classes customized learning and in the
classroom technology enhanced learning
and for each I'd just like to highlight
one observation and pose a critical
question or problem first you're all
familiar with flipped classes our six
different Muk related flipped classes at
Caltech have taken a great variety of
approaches inclass interactions are
blossoming from student team challenges
to collaborative problem solving and
more um but uh some of our flip classes
um have this gap between actual improved
learning and what students perceive
they're gaining from the courses so we
have this quandry um although overall
reactions are modestly positive the
classes just don't feel as difficult um
as expected despite these gains in
learning next the possibility of truly
customizing The Learning Experience
through mukes is really enticing we're
now seeing Muk tools being used to
introduce smallscale customizations
Within ctech classes for example
offering choices of learning materials
for a diversity of student prior
knowledge and developing on demand mukes
for working scientists and Engineers as
shown in the middle uh students uh seem
to appreciate modest customizations like
a Mastery approach uh with multiple
problem attempts and feedback our
question then is how can we accelerate
the availability of more deeply adaptive
components in mukes and finally muks at
celtech are Absol absolutely in dialogue
with non-mo Technologies the latter for
us are yielding some compelling insights
into real-time student engagement for
example in an iPad program in the
classroom we've been able to
characterize how students engage Through
Time series analyses both with faculty
and with each other as shown here on the
uh far right we're better understanding
why a few students dominate
participation in some cases as in the
upper panel and how to bolster more
students engagement as in the lower drop
off in the lower panel so we ask can
in-class techn can in-class technology
captured participation data like these
help inform Muk teaching and can next
generation analyses of Muk data give us
some actionable insights for oncampus
teaching thank
you
hi good afternoon I'm Linda Grisham from
Massachusetts Bay Community College and
Lyn Hunter also from Mass Bay uh we want
to talk about an experiment that was
done uh with the material from etex uh
uh to see how a computer science class
which is the entry class for uh non
computer science students at MIT how
would that material be useful or be
absorbed at a community college uh as
was mentioned earlier today
yes we have a lot of students when they
come in they're really not prepared um
math wise Etc we do a lot of work with
them uh so these are students in our
school who are comp uh computer science
students but they had very limited uh
programming uh uh experienceing stuff so
uh what was
done
um I'm can I get
this to move
over
thanks sorry about that um what was done
was that the material from
um is still
not yeah uh so what was done was the
instructor who was Hal rigs who
unfortunately couldn't be with us today
what he did he looked at the edex
material and it's very concentrated very
high quality but he sort of realized
that it really needed translation and so
what he did was to uh provide context uh
provide vocabulary provide practice
problems so that students could do this
the way he did this was to create a set
of of interactive tutorials and so every
week students would go through that and
having gone through that they were able
to do the material from addex do the
problems do the uh assignments take the
exam we started with 18 students uh two
dropped out immediately but all 16
actually completed the etex course with
the materials in the same time frame as
the regular course was there um the
elements for Success were these
tutorials because he really understood
what these students actually needed and
as time went on uh students met this was
a hybrid course they met for an hour and
a half but as time went on they would
work at home and they would come in and
work in groups and sort of peer-to-peer
tutoring
themselves when we met uh with the uh
edex group initially and an aunt uh was
there and asked us he said so what what
do you see of the benefit of the
materials and as a college administrator
former instructional designer I piped
right up and I said well this is high
quality content um and as as we all know
they're administrative and pedagogical
concerns or issues with any sort of
teaching experiment and uh IE agendas um
as an administrator I'm looking at cost
versus benefit and and those kinds of
things as well Linda instructional
design components so um but high quality
content we talk about that a lot what
does that mean and you can you can uh
sort of tease it apart in a lot of
different ways but one one way that we
were looking at it was um the edex video
lectures are are very high have very
high production values to them it's very
hard for a community college um like us
to produce quality videos like that we
just don't have the resources to do
those sorts of things um the quizzes
that were uh oops wow we're
over so the other key ingredient I'll
just mention um uh is what I would call
locally driven learner centered
pedagogically focused activity based
learning resources and that's what Linda
just mentioned how created thanks thank
you let's go forward with this
right hi so I'm Daniel seeden uh from
MIT uh but soon to be at Davidson is uh
as Christen said um so today I'm going
to be talking about teacher enrollment
in mitx mukes and hopefully a little bit
of dialogue about what this means uh for
course designers and uh platform
providers or designers um so why
teachers uh as part of as being part of
this movement from the very beginning uh
with 6 2x um there's been tremendous uh
well there have been a number of
experiments that showed teacher
enrollment whether it was a teacher
helping curate content in one of the
introductory physics courses whether it
was a teacher in Mongolia flipping his
classroom uh based on the 6 2x content
there have been a number of uh
situations that sort of make you realize
oh teachers are equally interested in
this um in this material as well and so
we might think about what it would mean
if large numbers of teachers were uh
present in these courses for example we
might be able to do some sort of expert
novice pairing and discussion forums um
we might be able to network Educators
many complaints uh and we've seen it in
some of these talks today are that a lot
of teachers in departments don't
necessarily share material so these
could be places where they could do that
um there's also a a potential for
Teacher professional development right
if teachers are already taking courses
why not find accreditation models for
them so that they can actually leverage
that in their own um professional
development uh and then as I said I
think there's really if there are
teachers there uh you could really
consider reshaping current courses and
infrastructure um but it all comes
around to a central question are a
significant number of teachers enrolling
so we surveyed um all the mitx courses
from this spring 2014 we have about
31,000 response which is responses which
is only about a 16.8% um uh response
rate but the results are striking um
about 28% of people across courses
identify as are having been teachers
right so that's one and four that's just
remarkable to think about um now in
terms of current teachers it's about 1
in 10 so
8.7% uh and then in terms of people who
have actually taught the topic uh and
I'm just focusing on these bullet points
below um it's about 6% so you can argue
that one and 20 people in these courses
have actually taught the material right
and that's rather startling when you
think about how we're design these
courses um now these numbers are I won't
explain the courses because of time um
but it's it's important to sort of also
frame this around their participation so
are they actively pursuing their
profession are they commenting in
discussion forms it's about the only
place you could do that and a comment in
this case is actually a reply to a post
right so if we take that as a proxy for
instruction uh we can ask well how many
people of of these populations of uh
survey participants are actually
commenting so here this is just a pie
chart showing that surveyed teachers are
3% of the total population uh 8% are
surveyed non-teachers and the rest is 80
about 89% so um you see the differences
in populations but when you look at how
much commenting is going on 22% is it 21
or 22 21 uh 21% are from surveyed
teachers and about 33% are surveyed
non-teachers and the rest come from
other people and that's just remarkable
right so they're actually teachers are
there and they're participating in these
courses um and so when you really frame
it in add way you can begin to say that
um for across courses one in 12 comments
is from a current teacher and one in 16
uh is from someone who has taught or has
experienced with the the topic and it's
just absolutely remarkable uh in my
opinion um you can even begin to have
playful anecdotes about student teacher
ratios I think one and 16 is what it is
typically for a high school uh in the US
and so in these muks we have something
similar um and so just to talk a little
bit about maybe the future there's many
questions remaining this is a it's a
first survey that we've done um but I
really think that this has a number of
implications one is reframing how we
treat demographics right there's the pen
reports the Harvard and mitx reports
talking about age and uh level of
Education this would certainly um change
our perspective there um it's also I
think and just to sort of follow up and
not read every bullet point uh there's
also some idea of how do we really
optimize uh sort of crowdsourcing of
teacher involvement and even how do we
optimize their experience through
accreditation models thank you
so if all the panelists could come back
up and join us in the
front and uh our colleague up there can
on Cas you a question okay um has a mic
and he's actually going to be looking
for you so if you could hold up your
hands if you have questions um and I
want to start with one actually um so
here's the mic and whoever wants to go
first um I'm going to start with this
issue around transparency of teaching
which I think is actually uh came right
out of Daniels I mean teachers are
interested in knowing what other
teachers are doing so how do you think
that's actually going to translate into
Better
Learning anyone to go for
that it's going all the way down to the
end it's a it's it's a great question
and in my opinion there's still a lot of
work to do by both um content teams and
um uh course providers there have to be
Tools in order to allow this group of
people to really uh impact the courses
and then impact learning uh so there's
actually it's quite surprising I think
to us that the percentages are so
consistent across courses uh and now
it's a matter of trying to leverage that
Collective Talent OR crowdsource
it anybody else want to add this concept
of trans transparency just in terms of
the Harvard faculty we work with all of
them when you go and talk to them about
developing their courses they like well
what is XY doing what like what does it
look like for what is everyone else how
are they adapting to this technology and
and working online so I think even for
people who aren't necessarily taking
mukes there's a huge amount of interest
in the way in which this teaching is
happening okay I saw a hand go up did
you already we again okay yeah and uh
Dan Gman from the University of
Washington and I also was going to pick
up on the teachers uh in mukes point you
know certainly when I was putting
together uh the mukas the first time for
the first time I thought a lot about my
colleagues who would surely be watching
and being very careful and in that sense
but still never imagined 6% and just to
add to your bullet list I find it really
intriguing to create a cohort of such
teachers not just for their own
networking and professional development
but because I made a thousand little
decisions when I put together my Muk and
I've never been able to explain them to
anyone and if that's what they're
interested in seeing why is he doing it
this way why was that problem chosen oh
that's an interesting example there's a
new opportunity for the moo instructors
to engage with this particular kind of
participant okay anybody all right I
have another one if oh you have one
okay he's
now go
ahead you can go first I just wanted to
follow up on that point as well I taught
a moo last year those was an
introduction to human evolution and one
of my goals given the topic was to
provide educational resources for
secondary teachers so that they could
bring that back into the classroom and
it was fantastic to get your
quantitative data because qualitatively
in the feedback we got after the course
there was lots of responses from
teachers and you know they said
everything from they would be
reincorporating you know lessons and
genetics based on this class into to
their high school classroom that they
had dropped because they' kind of lost
the inspiration um but I wondered um if
you had any thoughts for Best Practices
when it comes to creating the kind of
modular components and Licensing them in
the way so that High School teachers in
particular are more free to incorporate
them directly into their teaching in a
way that would be
effective I'd actually love our
colleagues at U Mass Bay to talk a
little bit about that because you guys
had to customize content we we we did C
customize the material so that students
could really absorb uh the academic uh
I'd say nutrition that was really there
um I think one of the issues is that
since they were not uh the Muk material
is not open you know I think it would
been nice to actually to be able to add
uh how rig's interactive uh resources
into that course for the students and it
it raises another kind of issue I think
is what goes on with teachers is that
especially K12 teachers and middle and
uh teachers faculty at community
colleges we teach we meet people where
they are and so there's actually a lot
of experience around the kind of
research questions that were raised by
Susan uh singer this this morning and I
I guess I put out a plea for that uh we
would really like uh people who want to
do research to work with us I mean it
really should be a two-way street
because there's a a lot of experience uh
we teach seven courses five seven
courses so obviously there's not a lot
of time to write papers or
anything yeah I was GNA say Davidson did
you have um yeah we are there's a second
edex project going on at Davidson
College that we're not directly involved
in but Daniel will be very soon um and
this is building uh modules for AP
courses for high school teachers and I
think the the thing that will make this
one very successful is the inclusion of
high school teachers in the the design
of this for Blended learning so we won't
just be providing the modules online
we'll be providing the scaffolding uh to
help them integrate activities that
happen in
class um I I don't remember the author
but there was a recent paper uh I think
it's a center for educational policy
where they listed a number of um key
issues facing teacher professional
development and one of those was around
sort of resources and their
implementation right and so there's a
big issue right now that there's a
one-day workshop with they say here's
great learning activities and here's
some resources but then they leave right
and so these teachers are by themselves
to uh to try to do this on their own and
so one part of having teacher networks
uh for example is that they can sort of
uh facilitate each other right uh and
help each other along the way as you
begin trying to implement those
resources so that's just a point to to
make too the resources by themselves
won't uh won't fully cut
it you uh hi I'm from Stanford uh this
is a question espe especially for
Professor cooperman who you talked about
you don't know a poem you uh experience
it uniquely and you you said about uh
you don't know a poem but you uh
experience it uniquely and that that
really was uh I think I'm trying to
understand that completely and by that
do you do you mean that we have heard in
uh sort of emphasizing assessment online
and whether we should be emphasizing
something else
maybe
collaboration and if in an Ideal World
if we could change everything about
online education what is it that you
would want us to emphasize most in these
online learning platforms I the it's a
long conversation but let me see if I
can if I can just say something very
brief I I think all of us have gotten
enthused uh me too by the possibility of
big data by the possib possibility of uh
getting people involved and so forth and
so on and we tend to focus a tremendous
amount on the
actual tent I mean they now can study
the big data from these courses to see
how often people um sign off sign on I
mean we can know so much more about how
people consume this material that's fine
I have yet to hear
about a moo well the problem was the
level of the con the level of the
material and how we're deciding to shape
it or what kind how we understand
philosophy these courses are largely uh
academic light uh and the form that
we're using in order to to address what
we perceive as the student
need there's no doubt it's a good idea
you should address the students but
you're making a choice when you do that
and you're never teaching the students
to go beyond the 8-minute attention span
or the three minute attention span or
the 15minute attention span we're not
giving them material to read outside of
class because that's not how Works muks
work so my suggestion is that we should
be looking at these things at least in
part the way we used to look at courses
that Professor is a brilliant person and
I don't always always understand more
than 20% of what he says but it's worth
thinking about what she said and going
into it and working at it and we can say
yeah but the kids won't do it well maybe
we have to figure out some way to do
that too so long I I
happy um okay my
phone I'm Merc Wes and I have a little
startup but I've been a computer science
educator for I think it's 30 six years I
was I taught my first programming class
here at MIT to um logo students um and I
I spend a lot of time in the computer
science education Community I want to
assure you that learning how to
program also requires having a very very
individual experience with coding and
with language and so if we can't do
poetry in the way that us old farts want
to teach and we can't do computer
science the way us old farts want to
teach then my question to all of you is
what should we be teaching with the
mukes and I'm just being as
controversial as you are I'm I'm I love
the technology I think it's really cool
I'm building the technology but I think
we are missing the point to some degree
that it's about what is this course do
or this module or this fragment or this
KH Academy video doing for this
individual student so that they can
become have a real genuine experience
with the
material what's in the middle
I'll answer sort of the other you know
they say how does a juice scratch his
ear um uh I always look for the other
way around it um one of the biggest
problems we had in the mukai taught was
peer evaluation because the students get
mad at each other and they don't
understand each other and things like
that um it's in a classroom you can kind
of control for that you can encourage
them to be individual and if they get
out of hand you can swap them and say
don't talk that way it's much harder to
do it in this thing and indeed yet I
think we should be building in ways to
accommodate it and it is dangerous it's
very difficult but we have to find some
way how Cassandra what about yeah I was
going to say the design part that she
was asking about who are these four you
guys are having some different
experiences why don't you share a little
bit well I'm not sure what quite what
you're getting at um but I can say that
I think I think it's hard to answer that
question in part because there are so
many very many different motivations and
audiences in mind for mukes and at
Caltech most of our faculty who have
taught these courses have been very
insistent that they remain as rigorous
and as um as kind of assuming of Prior
quantitative content knowledge as our
courses on campus have now that's a very
particular choice for our institution um
and it has a lot of implications as well
um so I I think it's it's tough to
answer the question but another thing
that we've we've also seen is is that
we're not always segmenting our lectures
down into eight minutes some of ours are
much longer um at the same time the flip
side of that is some of our courses have
really reer stood the structure of the
very Advanced material that they are
teaching by having to face the challenge
of thinking in terms of Concepts and the
right amount of time and the right sort
of sustained attention and student work
on a particular ular
area um one of the interesting things
from hearing everybody's comments is it
it's very clear that we really don't
have any common understanding of what a
Muk is um and it seems that I sort of go
back to the old Parable it's like you
know people are arguing that you know
it's a snake no it's a tree trunk and
it's an elephant um and every single one
of you all of us we're all taking our
own spin on what we understand and what
we want it to be on our campus is it
University is it an AP course is it a
learning community is it for faculty
development is it you know so I guess my
question would be is is how are you uh
perceiving it on campus Because I think
that one of the things that all of us
are trying to do is figure out how this
is going to impact what we're doing on
our campuses um and each University
seems to be taking a different sort of
take on that so that's sort of my
question to all of you is how what what
is it to
you I guess what is for us at a
community college is to provide uh Open
Access uh and uh an education for
students and so I see the mukes as
hopefully being a way to reach a wider
range of students uh who can't come to
campus or or those things that's what
I'm hoping
for okay without wanting to talk too
much uh uh just let me mention one other
thing uh muks are to some extent the
scariest thing campuses have seen in
generation uh University of Maryland um
has encourag muks in no small measure
because Penn State has online learning
and um uh muks and that allows Penn
State to steal our students because they
can't offer a degree in Maryland but
they can offer muks and uh that's going
on everywhere uh there's no doubt that
edex was in part a reaction
to the frightening fact of the rise of
this kind of new free education and and
the IVs were very worried about what is
that going to mean to their Monopoly uh
so that's another thing that these mean
is a new alternative model hasn't proven
to be a viable one yet but it may
be hi uh for USA Davidson I've thought
about it as sort of an R&D arm for
teaching and learning so it's a way of
building teams around building learning
experiences which is not the way that I
think learning experiences are typically
constructed they're typically
constructed by one faculty member in
front of a a group of students who give
them feedback at the end of the course
and instead this is an opportunity for a
team of people to develop a learning
experience and then get feedback from
potentially thousands and thousands of
people across the world and to learn
very quickly what's working and what's
not and hopefully build in some of those
lessons into what we do at at Davidson
uh so our first Professor ever to teach
uh a moo at Davidson Dr Erland Stevens
he actually said the reason in his
application to teach auk he said I want
to do this because I've taught my course
the same way for 10 years and I don't
really want to change it because I think
it works pretty well but I want to be
able to experiment with some new ideas
that I have and so he built this moo and
he taught it and
now it that's the case study I
referenced in my brief talk it's totally
transformed the way he thinks about
teaching in his own class and he's using
it to flip his classroom and and involve
his students as co-authors in course
material and as Tas so that we're only
at the very beginning of it when we've
been doing this for less than a year at
Davidson but already it's really
triggered uh some creative and out of
the-box thinking about what teaching and
learning can look like and how these
tools can enable things that we
previously weren't able to do or weren't
even
considering I just wanted to remark that
it's so easy to forget how much
heterogeneity there already is in
teaching and Academia we should
celebrate and treat as a blessing the
wide variety of things that go on even
in the same classroom on the same campus
in a given day because it's different
disciplines or it's people from
different Generations or it's simply
different styles and let's not
overgeneralize and let's hope that in
mukes going forward we have the same
variety let's hope that some mukes ask
you to study a 10line poem for 90
minutes and other mukes are perfectly
happy to have you watch two-minute
videos on your bus every morning right
this can be okay and I think it's just
important that we set expectations for
our students just like we always do and
I think that the participants in mukes
actually are not necessarily getting
this message because each moo kind of
looks the same and we've all said 8
minutes and we've all tried to do
whatever and I think we should do more
to say okay you signed up for this thing
here's an half hour description of what
it's going to be like and it's not going
to be like your other mukes this is
special this is how it's different and
we can have a lot of variety we don't
have to figure out the way to do a
moo go
ahead faster just to run and get it um I
love that we're getting back to the idea
of transparency so as we think about
building more uh transparent kind of
communities within muks which I think is
this very powerful idea that we've all
had thinking about the teachers who are
in the mukes um that's really the the
same idea as having our students in our
classes on campus becoming more
metacognitively aware understanding
their own process of learning so we're
really talking about expanding that
outward to a larger group as well so
thank
you um I'm an from Nova and um I started
at Corsair in 2012 and I've probably
worked with I don't know 30 or 50
professors of various institutions
including Dan Gman um and one thing that
I've noticed very broadly is that the
application of classroom technology
traditional classroom technology to
these new technologies is a flip to
student centered instruction and that's
really been across the board that you
know most professors at these
institutions are hired because of their
content knowledge and their content
expertise and this really forces them
when they go wide like we would say in
the movie business you know when you
open really big you have to think about
what the audience is thinking and so
suddenly even you know the first mukes
we delivered very broadcast style we
were getting all this feedback and so I
think it's just tremendous everything
that everyone is doing you know because
we're listening to students who are not
even our students who haven't been
screened you know by admissions offices
and they're telling us what we think and
so I just wanted to thank all of you for
doing such great work because I think
it's really can be transformative in how
we
proceive so I think the other thing
that's surfacing here is this um notion
of how much team we need in order to do
a mooch um and I think that also impacts
the transparency did some of you want to
talk a little bit about how that
impacted your teaching or how it
impacted your moo you know looking at
the team approach in terms of
design team you mean the group that
produces it or a group of teachers the
group that produces it uh well in my
case uh I think one of the things that
probably many of you have run into our
University gave us x amount of money
that amount of money we could use any
way we wanted I used it in part to pay
an experienced videographer who had the
ability to edit to take good uh uh photo
with two cameras and edit them together
and things like that and then I bought
the programming to edit that material
and so forth and so on I'm a novice when
it comes to this stuff but I spent that
money but I assure you I spent about
three times what the university gave me
to do it so these are expensive things
and the team universities if they really
want to sponsor muks have to do a lot
more in terms of building the providing
the services and building the team it's
not easy to do well David did you want
to add something you haven't
really uh at Georg Tech we have a
corsera support team and we work with
the instructor there is a platform
specialist somebody who knows about time
management and scheduling and I help
with the instructional design and set up
the research um support so that type of
that type of support for an instructor
is also very important whereas videos
are being produced there's somebody
there helping to critique that there's
an engineering staff there as well uh
who are quite competent at um capturing
videos and with excellent quality but I
think knowing that there's usually one
instructor who
is creating the moo putting the content
together but the Cera support team
helped for instance how how do you chunk
content that became a critical issue for
many of the instructors and without an
instructional design supporter I mean it
would be very difficult to you know
reduce content down to an 8 minute video
so I think I think that essence of team
is also very important not just the
instructional team but the support team
for the instructors to make some really
usable viable and robust
muks Davidson do you want to you guys
also used
a one of the um side effects to the team
approach that we had at Davidson I'm an
instructional technologist so the
majority of the work that I do tends to
be on the fringes or uh is an ad hoc
here and there within a course I'm
working on a project I'm in and then I'm
out in this case everyone on our team
who is involved in the creation of the
moo was equally invested as equally
invested as the instructor from start to
finish so we got to see the entire
curriculum process beginning to end
including all the outcomes in a way that
we hadn't done before and that has been
beneficial to our support of residential
courses as well so it's been it's been
tremendously helpful
yeah so uh part of what Harvard X
attempts to do is provide the team for
the faculty that they need because they
need so much so many resources and so
much time dedicated to this project um
and in the initial
phases Harvard X thought that a grad
student would be the Project Lead
helping the faculty and then we realized
that grad students are not have other
priorities and that so now we provide a
project lead for it who coordinates
graduate students and the faculty and
video production resources um but also
we serve as a as sort of a convening
place for the teaching and learning
resources on campus to help faculty
rethink their
approach often because they've been
teaching for 10 years and not that it's
ineffective but that they're just
excited about the opportunity of of
reformulating this
approach I think one of the
opportunities that we have before us um
is to blow a course apart and put it
back together again and I think the
technologies that we're talking about
make it easier to do that and more in a
more tangible and visible way to do that
um and I'm you know we hear a lot about
the local teams working instructional
design teams working institution by
institution perhaps one of the next
Frontiers will be uh opening the team
approach up into more of an open source
inspired model where you have um cross
institutional or even larger uh groups
of people working on let's say a
psychology course what is a psychology
course supposed to be some of the larger
questions and I'll stop there
uh I'm wondering uh obviously we didn't
develop that but we were very impressed
by the edex team when we were uh
planning for the running the course in
the spring uh I see this as Lynn was
saying as an opportunity to rethink a
number of things and their outcomes that
I guess institutions talk about which is
that they want to bring in
underrepresented communities Etc um
maybe those some of those folks should
be on those planning teams as well right
absolutely another facet of teams that
we might consider are those who are
going into the future profession of
teaching either at the University level
or in the K through 12 environment um
one of the reasons perhaps that uh the
stem fields at least our fields are not
adopting um evidence-based teaching
strategies as quickly as they might is
that their mentors are less
knowledgeable about those forms of
teaching so if we have an opportunity
to give experience to some of our upand
coming um colleagues I think that's one
that we should not
waste Dan so just as a brief
Counterpoint uh to the staff support
team uh the five mukes out of my
department including my own essentially
rolled with no such staff support
faculty undergraduate ta staff a little
bit of it support and we made it up as
we went along um it's a little extra
work for the faculty in some ways the
students have to learn how to do their
own video editing but it it can be
done we have one over here uh Doug fiser
Vanderbilt University uh Kathy cerly
made a comment uh this morning or in her
talk that um she thought that um it was
not important you you create your Co
your own content your own content will
not always be better than the other
person's and I don't think for lifelong
teachers that is the primary motivation
I think the primary motivation is to get
the excitement that some of the people
that have created mukes get when they do
put their own courses online I I think
that's the primary motivation and I
think we have to tell uh teachers that
it's just as exciting to use somebody
else's content and flip your classes um
that's the way I sort of got excited
about teaching after 25 years of using
PowerPoint now everybody wants the show
we've got one over here one over here
one over there go ahead mine's not a
followup but I I just
okay go ahead oh um so there was a sort
of builds a little bit on Doug's point
but also uh you and you made the comment
about evidence-based practice I'm
curious um are any of you using the data
that's being generated by your
implementations of your courses to
Target where the courses need to be
improved how they need to be improved
and sort of starting that continuous
cycle of uh data driven continuous
Improvement so I can respond to that uh
the course that I spoke about in here
the uh circuits and electronics course
is now in its fifth revision and each
time the course is offered surveys are
administered in fact after each module a
survey is administered and the students
are asked to what extent was the video
difficult was it difficult was it easy
and perhaps um did the video help you
learn the course material so we get
information like that from the students
and we take that information and then we
refine the course of also we're looking
at course assessments the embedded
assessments and the videos uh module
assessments Etc so all of this is
playing into refining the
course anybody
yet uh so my my current role uh at MIT
is a data analyst and so essentially all
the mitx data comes through uh
institutional research where I work and
and I curate and do uh analytics on the
data and I I'd say that I think largely
there's still a large there's a big gap
between um uh course staff and our
analysis uh so I've tried to push more
in the direction of um uh course
specific issues where there just number
of times of people access content um
anything that I talk to I see safe in
the back and I always pick on them
during talks um U but so uh safe is one
of those examples uh they have a lot of
assessment their courses but they never
get information back about who does what
and so that's still something that's
very lacking I think um at MIT hopefully
nobody will I won't get in trouble for
that but there's still a big
gap anybody else just one small comment
I think uh for me I think from on on the
front end of developing these courses
there's so much that's going through
your mind and there's so much that I I
don't understand about what we're
building I think you have to set up
specific goals and hypotheses right from
the beginning and order to do that well
and I think for the average institution
we're not thinking that way and we don't
often times have the capacity or
expertise to do that and so I I think
actually that's a huge opportunity for
collaboration among institutions because
little Davidson College won't
necessarily have the teams we need in
the long run to develop these hypotheses
and experiments in a in a a really
rigorous way so that's that's one area
love to work with any of you on that you
yeah uh it may be a slight rephrasing of
what Canon said uh but I I see there is
a scale uh or there are orders of
magnitude of students and what you can
do with 100 students is different from
what you can do with a thousand students
and I'm I'm curious as to how have you
used the feedback that you've gotten
from these students in different ways I
I have a hunch that maybe Howard X uses
the feedback or gathers the feedback
differently than say if I were running a
Muk which had fewer students
uh so if any of you could say how you've
used feedback that You' gotten from
students I don't think of it as data I
just think of it as what are your
students seeing and how are you using
that we might not get the uh uh circuits
and electronics course started out using
the moo to deliver the content this was
uh last summer and what was really
fascinating about this we used the
flipped approach the students viewed the
videos online and then they came to
class they worked on problems and then
they also did some experimentation
Hands-On in in the classroom in
diets a focus group revealed that the
students did not like the flipped
approach they felt disconnected from
what they were watching in the videos
and what was happening in class as we
moved to a blended approach those
complaints dissipated the students began
to see what they were doing in class
class was helpful and what they were
learning outside of class was also
helpful and these two sep what were
disperate at first were now United in
the classroom with that 10minute lecture
and that's the Blended approach that's
how we operationally Define
it I was just going to add something
that people in this room who are younger
than I and I think probably most of you
are um uh might have a stronger reaction
to this it seems to me that one of the
implications of the modern way that we
consume knowledge and it has to do with
the the the internet and Google and it
has to do with Facebook is that the
authority structures that used to exist
uh have disappeared so you used to come
to the university you were a farm child
you came to the university the professor
there knew everything and you uh only
knew your cows and so for and so on and
that's that's gone to some extent the
feedback is so varied from the vast
number of people who take your course
that it forces even people as old as I
am to realize that the Authority or what
they think they're teaching has very
little to do with what those people
are um accepting or internalizing and so
I think one of the results is to
liberate the professor and to begin to
look to in Inspire the students
individually by throwing out problems
rather than by telling them what to
think we'll just do one more and then we
got to wrap up one other just one other
quick piece of your comment was about
scale in a moo what can we do when we
have thousands and thousands of people
studying and working on something
together that we can't do when we have
10 or 20 or 50 or or 100 and I think
that's a fantastic Horizon goal we're
doing citizen science with distributed
networks of people producing new
knowledge um one of our dreams is to run
simulations with you know thousands of
students in a class that wouldn't be
significant or possible with just our
students on campus so I think that's a
great direction to think about going can
you join me in thanking our
panelists go out to the buses Candace
says